joining us now Fox News contributor
kellyane Conway and Fox News contributor
Jason Chaffetz you know it's almost I
want to say it's staggering kellyanne to
hear that but their defense is of course
they should be doing that that's the
defense of the White House of course
they should be directing private
companies to take on disinformation and
defensive democracy do we expect any
other defense from them
no but fortunately Pete she's got very
little credibility in almost anything as
you point out she had some Russian title
to handle the southern border as of May
2022 a good seven months ago they
basically gave up on that no more root
cause day trips to Central America no
more visits she between she and
President Biden they have visited the
Border a grand total of one time and she
wasn't even close to the Border he's
been to Delaware 174 days of his
presidency he's been to the Border zero
and I think her reaction to what's going
on with Twitter is typical commonly
here's someone who is the Attorney
General of the State of California Tech
Central and she was United States
Senator representing that state now the
vice president and she's so reactive
instead of talking about free form
instead of talking about what Elon Musk
is trying to do what other tech
companies could be doing to make sure
that we the citizenry don't feel Shadow
band don't feel censored don't feel like
they have this out outside outsized
power to control content especially so
close to an election but I just want to
go as Kamala and kjp would say I want to
Circle back for a second this White
House On the Border is lying to us every
single day but if you look at the
polling Kareem Jean-Pierre is lying to
us at the border is closed it's not open
and the majority of Americans say in
fact the Biden policies have opened the
Border they hold them responsible for
the crisis that we have at the southern
border and so not only is she lying but
she's basically saying to more than half
of the country you're either being
dishonest or misled and it is not
compassionate to allow three million
people here there are 17 States in our
nation right now that have a population
of Less Than 3 million and it's not
compassionate to have people sleeping in
30 degree weather to have 10 and 12 year
olds making that Crossing by themselves
I know because we used to have the
briefings in the Trump Pence White House
what happens to many of those young
people and so what's happening with the
fentanyl everything that you said it's
so incredibly important for people to
realize that even in these blue cities
like Denver Gavin Newsom El Paso's
Democratic mayor even Arizona's
governor-elect they all see Eric Adams
governor of New York City saying that
the migrants are displacing the homeless
in New York City I have to just say I
think that we're going to start seeing a
fraying of the partisanship here and
Biden and Harris are going to be on the
outs there
hmm interesting that would be actually
very interesting if that did occur has
it really happened so far so far a lot
of that calling out of the
administration is to get more money not
necessarily to solve the Border prices
which I know you you know as well Jason
when it comes to Twitter to hear Kamala
Harris they at least asked about the
Twitter files which the media has mostly
not and they've totally ignored but when
she her answer was the revealing
underbelly of the modern left which is
yes that's exactly what we should be
doing censoring people who we don't
think are telling our side of the story
yeah she used the word require uh she's
the vice president of the United States
she would require social media media
companies to do as she sees fit uh first
of all we're not a democracy we're we're
a constitutional republic thank you and
you know what she she wants her her way
uh they want a one-way Street they want
to be able to communicate with the
masses without the Republicans or
conservatives or any dissenting voice to
question their Authority and that's the
way they've operated that's the way the
Department of Justice has seen fit this
is why we have 80 FBI agents not working
on Counter Intelligence not working
about the about China not worried about
Russia not worried about the slangs in
Idaho no they're working on making sure
that this Administration uh is uh has a
full Fetter just an open Lane to do what
they see uh fit and I gotta tell you you
got a president that mumbles and you got
a vice president who's really good at
the word salads you really don't know
exactly what they say saying and then
you've got a White House spokesperson
who goes up there and she just reads and
and doesn't even actually tell the truth
so it's really hard to decipher
it sure is uh Kelly I'm intrigued on the
political side about what you said do
you anticipate some Democrats who could
see the obvious in front of them turning
maybe they have presidential Ambitions
truly turning against the White House on
this and saying our border is out of
control do you see that
maybe it starts with Senators like
Kirsten Cinema maybe even Mark Kelly
will find the courage and the Moxie to
speak up of course you know people like
that he votes for the 87 000 new IRS
agents and doesn't really fund our
border agents but I was really struck by
Gavin Newsom I mean you know he's a a
pretty boy with presidential aspirations
as if the rest of us want to be
California but for him to go to the
border and say if we have this migrant
influx indefinitely it'll quote break
California uh you have again mayor Adams
just today saying This is basically not
fair to New York residents who already
don't have the resources the Democratic
mayor of El Paso to to break with them
so I do think you're starting to see it
won't get it covered as much so thank
you for covering it but it's going to
have to start with some of these
Democratic senators maybe some of the
presidential Ambitions but some who just
want this White House to stop with this
entire standard operating procedure of
don't believe what you see with your own
two eyes believe what I Joe Biden and
Kamala Harris
say
there we go Kelly and Jason thank you so
much great analysis hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else